hey guys it is Friday which means if you
haven't been paying attention to gaming
news this week then you don't have to
worry because I've got you covered
here's what mattered oh yeah this week
Microsoft announced to that yet another
fan favorite game is joining the
backwards compatible catalog the
publisher have revealed that call of
duty black ops will now be backwards
compatible and playable on Xbox one
microsoft confirmed the game would join
the lineup in november of last year but
didn't signal when it would actually
arrive there are currently over 170
backwards compatible titles and if you
want to know just what those might be
you can check out the full list on
gamespot microsoft also confirmed that
multi-disc xbox 360 games are now
supported the first which is deus ex
human revolution director's cut warner
brothers confirm the remasters of batman
arkham city and Batman Arkham Asylum
would be coming in a bundle called fat
man returned to Arkham following the
announcement reddit user black fire 561
took a selection of scenes from the
returned to Arkham trailer and found
corresponding shots from the original
together better look at the new graphics
which have been redone with Unreal
Engine 4 as you can see they look pretty
damn good both Arkham City and Arkham
Asylum were originally developed in
Unreal Engine 3 3 monsters are set to
feature upgraded models environments
lighting effects and shaders returns
Arkham is set to arrive on July 26 and
will cost 50 bucks if you're really and
I mean really excited for the upcoming
Assassin's Creed movie then you may want
to check out with these pre-order
packages apparently pre-ordering movie
tickets alone is going out of style
since now you can get all sorts of merch
for more of your hard-earned dollars
available on the website colonel you can
drop fifteen dollars for a package with
the movie ticket and an official digital
copy of the script or if you have money
to burn you can spend twelve hundred
dollars on those two items plus a
to-scale spanish cross / replica of the
weapon featured in the movie I'll the
packages include a six-hundred-dollar
premier scale statue of a SAS
Aguila and official hoodie for 120 bucks
or a toil iguales hidden blade for sixty
dollars which you can use to threaten
the guy sitting next to you who bought
the cool crossbow cam but shouldn't
Microsoft has confirmed to Game Informer
that the price of xbox live gold is
increasing in six countries the unlucky
few include austria-hungary Israel South
Africa Sweden and tacky a South African
reader alerted the publication that the
price was set to triple to the
equivalent of ten dollars and
thirty-three cents US per month
Microsoft told Game Informer they
occasionally update pricing to fall in
line with currency fluctuations within
the region and the changes will come
into effect on jun 20 of this year
finally this week EA explained why star
wars battlefront didn't have single
player and teased that the sequel mesh
eh Studios boss Patrick soderlund said
they deliberately left out any single
player campaign to ensure the game would
come out before Star Wars The Force
awakens released in cinemas that said
soderlund said he's not happy with the
average review score of 75 out of 100 he
said the lack of a single player
campaign was one of the main criticisms
and that they're looking to rectify that
the next time around let me know down in
that comment section if you thought star
wars battlefront suffered from a lack of
single-player this week on site that we
talked about the most impactful mods
Dave wraps up the wild world of
Warhammer on in two minutes and we
talked about the best features from the
escape from tarkov alpha that is
everything I have for you this week so
be sure to let me know what you care
about and I will see you again on Monday